Skywalker has risen and the nine-part Skywalker
saga has ended.
We've misplaced our Jedi Holocrons nd our
Sith Wayfinder accidentally got flushed down
the space-toilet, so all we can do is make
some educated guesses about what the ending
of Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker all meant.
Spoilers incoming.
For a movie franchise that's generally regarded
as science fiction, there sure are a lot of
supernatural and probably ectoplasmic beings
hanging around the galaxy in Star Wars.
Of course, we're used to seeing Force Ghosts
by now.
Ever since Obi Wan told Luke to turn off his
dang iPhone so he could shoot his torpedoes
into the Death Star's exhaust port, fans have
accepted the fact that when you're strong
with the Force, you get to play extra innings
as a glowing blue person.
And when Yoda himself showed up in The Last
Jedi to mess with Luke and set an old tree
on fire, it became clear that the Force Ghosts
in Star Wars were going to do a bit more than
dispense wisdom and exposition.
So that's our best guess as to who - or what
- that crowd of creeps might've been hanging
around with Emperor Palpatine on Exegol at
the movie's end: Force Ghosts.
Palpatine made a big deal about how all of
the Sith were fueling him, and it seemed as
though the hooded figures who faded in and
out of view during the scenes with the Emperor
were some kinds of spectral Sith lords.
Meanwhile, Rey's cosmic pep talk at the end
of the film came courtesy of Jedi Force Ghosts
— and even featured the voice talents of
Jedi actors past and present, including Hayden
Christensen and Ewan MacGregor reprising their
roles as Anakin Skywalker and Obi-Wan Kenobi
from the prequel trilogy, among many others.
One of the most dramatic plot developments
in the film came in the form of Kylo Ren's
reversal and transformation back into his
previous identity of Ben Solo.
His redemption was one that was preordained
from the first moment we learned he was Han
and Leia's son in The Force Awakens.
Not only that, but he's this trilogy's version
of Darth Vader, who himself had a rather famous
redemption of his own at the end of Return
of the Jedi.
As such, the chance that he would close out
the series as a full villain seemed pretty
remote.
Even still, Kylo Ren's turnaround might've
seemed kind of abrupt, so why and how did
he turn to the light?
Even though he ended each film playing the
part of the villain, Kylo Ren expressed conflict
and doubts about his ability to fully commit
to the First Order and the Dark Side in each
episode.
With each film, Ren seemed unable to fully
accept his decision to go bad - and in so
doing, acted out like an angry baby, slashing
consoles with his lightsaber, and smashing
his helmet out of frustration.
So when Leia expended all her willpower trying
to reach her son one last time - apparently
going so far as to pull an Obi Wan to sacrifice
herself for the good of her kid - it may have
opened the door for him to actually see the
light side again.
From there, Rey's own sacrifice of her Force
energy to heal the fatal wound she dealt him
probably sealed the deal.
Near the very end of the film, Maz Kanata
hands Chewbacca a cute little medal, saying
that Leia would've wanted him to have it.
The moment kind of comes out of nowhere, but
chances are good that folks in theaters were
pretty happy when the scene unfolded.
If you're wondering why, the answer can be
found 42 years in the past.
Back at the end of the first Star Wars film,
A New Hope, Han and Luke are awarded medals
by Princess Leia in a ceremony that's full
of smiles and great John Williams music.
But despite having just as much to do with
her rescue and the destruction of the Death
Star as anyone, poor Chewbacca didn't get
jack squat.
Chewie's medal neglect has been a sore point
for Star Wars fans for decades, so it's only
fitting that he finally gets his due in this
last movie.
Additionally, the medal was probably the one
Leia had originally given to Chewbacca's life-mate
Han, which gives the moment even more significance.
So what was this movie actually about?
Well, beyond the obvious answer of "wars...in
the stars," this is a movie that pins its
emotional core on the idea of togetherness.
To lay it out simply, The Rise of Skywalker
is about how working together is good, and
going it alone is bad.
It sounds pretty corny when it's put that
way, but the strength of that theme is undeniable.
Think about it: Rey can't succeed without
help from Ben Solo, and in the end she relies
on the will of all the past Jedi to help her
defeat Palpatine.
Moreover, Finn and Poe go to great lengths
to keep their party together this time around.
This is all in stark contrast to the events
of The Last Jedi, a movie that also proves
the same theme to be true, though it does
so in the exact opposite way.
When Finn and Rose break off from the Resistance
to help Poe undermine Admiral Holdo, disaster
follows.
And Luke's decision to abandon his sister
and the Republic leaves the galaxy open to
the rise of the First Order - as well as,
apparently, the rise of the Final Order and
the resurrection of the Emperor.
Meanwhile, Rey and Kylo Ren's connection in
The Last Jedi set up their deeper alliance
in The Rise of Skywalker, and eventually led
to the final destruction of the Empire.
That connection is fully realized at the end,
when she takes on his family's name of Skywalker
and completely embraces her adopted family
as her actual one.
So with the end of the First Order, the Final
Order, the Emperor, and the Supreme Leader,
who's in charge of the galaxy now?
If your answer is the Republic, well, you're
wrong there too, since they got exploded back
in The Force Awakens.
It's an easy detail to forget, since we never
really got to see what Leia's newly established
New Republic could do as an intergalactic
governing body, but maybe it's just as well.
The answer to the question of who's in charge
is, basically, no one.
The free planets are free, and maybe a new
galactic government will get together to debate
trade routes and taxation, just like the good
ol' days.
Or maybe they won't!
Or maybe Rey will decide to take on the role
of Empress after all - but she'll be a good
one, and she'll rename the Star Destroyers
something nicer… like Star Deployers.
There's no end to the possibilities!
The final scene of the film shows Rey burying
the two lightsabers that once belonged to
Luke and Leia at the Lars family homestead
on Tatooine.
It's a nice scene that symbolically plants
seeds for the future of this franchise in
an interesting way.
Even though the Skywalker Saga has come to
an end, the galaxy is still an awfully big
place full of people who'll find connections
to the Force, and may end up searching for
answers.
That may lead them to Tatooine, which could
potentially become a holy site to future generations
of Force users.
The future of Star Wars as a film franchise
is a huge question mark, though we know that
Kevin Feige, the architect of the mega-successful
Marvel Cinematic Universe, is working on his
own ideas for forthcoming Star Wars movies.
Whether we ever see Finn, Poe, Rey, or even
Lando or Chewbacca ever again remains to be
seen.
But while those lightsabers may be buried
in the sand, it stands to reason that we'll
see those legendary weapons from a galaxy
far, far away again before too long…
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.